Two budding entrepreneurs,
(crowd clapping)
will face off to win major prizes
that will help boost their businesses even further.
So are you ready to meet some of the businesses?
(crowd cheering)
Check this out.
(crowd clapping)
Hey everyone, I'm Jasmine.
Hey I'm Justin.
We are husband and wife team
and also the co-founders of our company Morning Joy Co.
I'm one of the founders of Hank Sauce.
I'm the founder and creative director of Mokuyobi.
I'm the co-founder and CEO of Cee Cee's Closet NYC.
I am the founder of Estelle Colored Glass.
I own The Craft Studio.
I am the owner and operator of Farmer's Daughter Fibers.
I am the owner and operator of the Del Norte Studio.
To Drew, thank you so much for finding us
and in featuring us on your website.
It means so so much to us.
Hundreds of followers since then,
tons of online orders.
That people obviously trust whose opinions
she's got great taste.
This holiday season was truly,
the busiest one we've had
in the last five years.
Due to the fact that we were featured
in The Drew Barrymore Show.
Thank you seriously so much,
for all that you're doing to support small businesses.
We appreciate you taking the time to do this.
For us and for everyone else that you've supported as well.
Hey, I'm Krystn and I own Keller Works Naturals.
I started my business nine years ago,
because my son Elliot has severe eczema
and I couldn't find soap on the market to meet his needs.
Since then, we've done a lot of really cool things.
One of the most exciting,
has been being featured on Drew Barrymore social media.
Soon after, the orders started pouring in.
We can hardly manage.
We're so super grateful for the opportunity
that she's given us.
We are the owners of Kernels Nashville Popcorn.
We specialize in freshly pop glommed popcorn,
including Nashville hot popcorn.
We are a family owned business.
And when you come to Kernels
you are a part of our family too.
Thank you so much Drew Barrymore Show for featuring us.
(Thank you Drew.)
(crowd cheering)
This So cool.
And I have to thank our digital team and the producers..
And everyone who wrote in on my personal social media,
when I made this call to action.
So that we can highlight these small businesses.
So, every single one of them is amazing.
And we've got many to continue to shine a light on,
but for now we've chosen two
for our first small business challenge.
So please welcome Krystn Keller
the founder of Keller Works in Mobile, Alabama.
And sisters Erica, Amber and Jennifer,
the founders of kernels Nashville Popcorn
in Nashville Tennessee.
(crowd cheering)
Hey,
Hey Drew.
Oh, I'm just so happy to be doing this with you guys.
And I know,
Thank you
this is so personal for you.
So thank you for letting us into our world.
And today you're gonna to have to pitch,
your businesses.
And I'd like to welcome my fellow judge,
who is a dear friend.
In 2002, she started her own business
out of her bedroom with just $500.
And today her company is valued at over a billion.
That's a billion with a B, dollars.
(Jeniffer laughing)
Wow !
Is a woman I would ask business advice
from any day of the year.
Please welcome the incredible Kendra Scott.
(crowd cheering)
I'm so happy to meet your amazing female founders.
What a treat for me today to be here..(indistinct)
Yes!
Nice to meet you too.
Well, ladies would you like to know,
what you're playing for?
Yes.
Okay.
Let's take a look.
The winner of today's small business challenge will win big.
They will receive a marketing package
which includes a feature on the homepage
of our show's website.
A one-on-one meeting with the one and only Kendra Scott.
Whose award-winning company is worth a billion dollars.
That's billion with a B.
In addition,
the winning business will also receive a consultation
with top PR executive and branding expert, Alison Brod.
Who has worked with companies such as L'Oreal, Old Navy,
Bed Bath and Beyond and Burger Kings.
And to top it off today's winner
will also receive a $10,000 dollar cash prize.
(crowd cheering)
(Kandra laughing)
Thank you.
(indistinct)
So are you ready for your small business challenge?
First step,
Krystn, what is your pitch and what is your story?
Hi, I'm Krystn.
I'm the founder of Keller Works Naturals.
We're a sensitive skincare company.
We make products for people with eczema and allergies.
Nine years ago,
my little boy Elliot developed a rash on his face.
And it quickly spread all over his body.
We took him to about 14 different doctors
and found out that it was caused by eczema
from his allergies.
So I looked and looked,
for products to help maintain his skin.
And I couldn't find anything for his allergies
which led me to create my own skincare line.
Within two weeks, the rash had completely cleared.
Everyone around us noticed,
and they said, "what did you use and where do I get it"?
That's when I knew I had a business
and there was a need and I could fill it.
Thank you so much for you for the opportunity
to be on the show.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you, Krystn.
And Kendra, do you have a question for Krystn?
Yes.
So what does your company competitive landscape look like?
Who are you competing against?
And what makes your product stand out from theirs?
My competitors that I usually focus on,
are companies like Survey,
but the leg up that I have on that,
is the fact that we're all natural
and we use no chemicals whatsoever in our product.
I know you think that,
that what separates you,
is some of just what's put in the product?
What separates you, is you.
Your story, your experience
your relate-ability to other mothers and parents.
You have that over any one of your competitors
that are in drug stores across America.
So celebrate that.
Absolutely. That's excellent advice.
Thank you so much
Erica, Amber, Jennifer, it's your turn.
What is your pitch and what is your story?
Okay, so we are the sisters of kernels Nashville Popcorn.
Our story starts a long time ago when we were kids.
Our parents always got us the popcorn tins for Christmas,
you know, the Carmel cheddar butter.
And we just gobble it up every,
every holiday season.
And so it just became a family tradition. So,
We fast forward seven years,
and it was Christmas break of 2007.
And we were just sitting around casually talking
and Jennifer has the idea.
"what did we have opened a popcorn store in Nashville"?
'cause there wasn't one anymore.
And when she said that,
I just immediately envisioned like what it could grow into.
What it could be.
So in 2008,
we started doing events and festivals
and we started gaining a following.
And So we decided to open a store for.. in 2013.
And now kernels has 14 delicious flavors.
Yes
Kendra, what are your thoughts
and what are your questions?
First of all,
I see when I was kind of reading about you guys,
you have big dreams for this business.
You want it to go bigger,
Yes.
Right?
You wanna be able to build your online.
How are you going to do that and compete
you think, against other popcorn businesses out there?
What makes us set apart
is the experience that you have when you come to Kernels.
We treat you like family.
Yeah.
Mh
Definitely.
I'm just so,
I love that because in our stores at Kendra Scott,
we have what's called the 'Kendra Scott sister rule'.
Is treat your customer like your sister.
And then your customer service is really easy.
(indistinct)
Right?
And so you guys have,
(indistinct)
that create experience.
I love all of those things.
So great job there.
Thank you
Kendra,
Yes.
I think that we both agree,
that these businesses are deserving.
And, I think Kendra and I feel,
that the winners should be both of you.
Both businesses.
(crowd cheering)
Thank you.
And,
You are each going home,
with a one-on-one meeting with Kendra Scott.
(crowd cheering)
And feature on the homepage
of our show's website with a ton of support
and a consultation with top PR executive
and branding expert, Alison Brod.
And then we're gonna throw in $10,000
for both of you as well.
(crowd cheering)
Krystn, Erica and Amber, Jennifer.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you too.
And Kandra.
Ooh!
I just love doing this with you so much.
Thank you.
So go to our website
to learn more about these small businesses and our others.
(upbeat music)